before you go into the ground and You're
Dead Forever try one store your dream
your Aesthetics your menu your formula
your product just go for it once
attention is the number one asset let's
kick it right off uh the Arbitrage is
here is I spent all summer selling cards
on eBay to join a Fanatics live stream
and win an auction to what I think I
stole to grab 15 minutes of your time so
uh eBay I mean I've been following you
for years we're obviously all in on the
vending we're all in on the cards the
books the the whole nine so uh we we run
a podcast and we want to give back to
our our people our staff our employees
and we've got you know a couple
questions teed up for you I want to just
like introduce ourselves real quick um
and and go from there and see where that
takes us and uh just holy crap we're so
blessed to even uh you know have a
little bit of your
timeon Justin's voice is shaking
you guys are being very very sweet thank
you for the all the swag that's on the
tables and everything I'm ready to rock
and roll I'm excited to be here with
you got the black cat got the 10 ants
that I know you saw earlier today and I
launched on Courage stream last night so
um this is Chris Alexa our CEO we're
aspire to be Hospitality 16 restaurants
Buffalo wildwing Starbucks and this is
Kimberly Alexa our CFO so uh we wanted
to be sensitive of our time we each kind
of have a question teed up for you um
you know kind of specific to our
industry and your expertise and we
wanted to rock and roll so Kim us off
yeah so and forgive me I wrote my
question down just because I I'm so Star
Struck I didn't want to get preoccupied
but my question really is evolved around
like our podcast and Next Level and we
have this we have run this for a very
short time around 10 months our podcast
but my question is what are some
strategies or tactics that you recommend
for Us increasing our podcast audience
engagement and and increasing our loyal
customer um base right now we're at
around 500 subscribers and over the next
six months we have a goal to reach a
thousand so what strategy specifically
that you can help us out with to reach F
go from 500 to a th in a six-month
pretty short time
span um for uh many things one how often
are you doing the
podcast we well it's once a week we are
releasing our our podcast once a week
and then we have episodes
so Tuesday morning we release one
yeah our episode this is our third
episode no worries how did you get how
did you get the original
500 just originally just organically
organically organically I mean we're
gaining 5 to 10 a week every episode
we've done 30 episodes and 290 shorts
which are just basically shorts or Clips
within the episodes yeah makes sense are
and you're filming the
episodes yes sir yes sir and are you
this is our studio without the lights
this is and so for me the way I would do
it is you film the episodes and I would
chop up the highlights and I would focus
on
LinkedIn and I would target employees I
would run media to amplify
that content of employees of other
Hospitality groups on
LinkedIn okay yeah that's that's a we
haven't hit LinkedIn we're on every
other one but not LinkedIn so LinkedIn
to me is is disproportionately the most
fruitful platform for y'all because
you're a
B2B conversation more than a b Toc
conversation so people's mindset in
consuming content in LinkedIn is much
more business content oriented plus the
way that LinkedIn ads work you can post
a con piece go 37 second clip or
two-minute clip that you think is really
great from the show and then you can
literally run $1,000 in ads or $500 in
ads against employees of these seven
different Hospitality groups who clearly
would be more likely to be interested in
what you're talking
about you could also
pretty cool but think about it you could
also go broader than that obviously you
can run against employees of this
restaurant group or that one but you can
also run against employees of marott you
can run it against employees of Taco
Bell like there's a lot of different
ways you could Target your media and
these are like three four $500 media
spends not
400,000 okay yeah good totally makes
sense y thank you yeah cool thank you
that's a good that's a good question a
good answer that helped out a lot so
Chris has a I've got one more for you
all three of you need to go to your
phone and you need to all go to your
phone one weekend grab a glass of wine
go to
contacts start at the letter
a and hit up Aaron
Anderson and text him and say hey Aon
hope you've been well we haven't spoken
since high school
here's a link to my podcast it would
mean a lot to me if you would listen and
I would end with Zar
Zaron and do that for a week or two
until you're done with a toz but
literally directly sending a link to the
podcast and then obviously adding a
sentence or two because some people you
haven't talked to in a year and it might
seem out of touch and other people you
might have talked to last week but
you're just very transparent I'm really
been I'm doing this podcast I'm really
pass about it mean the world to me if
you listen to
it okay yeah that's great we thought
about that but never pulled the trigger
on that yeah yeah we're kind of
intimidated by that right we don't want
to thend our friends we pushing
ourselves off them that's right that's
right you don't spam them that's right
this is why you have the link and you
have to take time and write a custom
thing you're not control C control V and
and spamming everyone you're literally
going to Barry Bond and saying Hey Barry
you know like and don't forget this in
your contacts you have a lot of former
employees former business associates by
the way you may want to say to one of
them or 10 of them or hundred of them
hey would love to have you on the
podcast oh yeah yeah I love it yeah I
like the thing about drinking the wine
too at the same
time that's good yeah love it yeah
that's awesome yeah all right cool uh
let's Chris is our fearless leader he's
got one teed up for you yeah so Gary um
as you can see this is my nft right here
the bullet schol and that's who I am
right me and Kim started this company
back at we were 26 and no college
education and bought my first franchise
as quiz know and me and her work those
stores to death every day of the week
until we grew to two and then we sold
those and grew this this brand and this
we changed our company name to Aspire to
be and that's what it is aspire to be
more we're just out here trying to
change other people's lives too just as
you're doing too so but we're we're part
of six different brands Starbucks
Buffalo's Arby's as a CEO I'm always
sitting in my office I spend a little
bit of time of always dreaming and
visionize what's our next step what are
we doing next we are so saturated with
the restaurant as when covid hit I mean
it killed us all right and it was like
I've always tried to diversify what can
we do next and I'm always looking out
there and I want to kind of want your
advice I've looked at other things too
and I'll use this for example like
energy drinks I mean we sell a lot of
Red Bull in our bars and and and a lot
and then one of the things Kim Envision
was was a slip resistant shoe can we get
in a Sho line because we have a thousand
employees if not more that are buying
these you know Sketcher shoes and is
there anything that you can throw at me
that you might can let us look at that
we should be looking at in this
business I believe the natural step for
you to go for the Grand Slam is to
become the franchise
or yeah I believe if I'm if I was if you
guys were my first cousins and we were
always family vacationing at the level
and scale that you just referred to I'd
be bothering you on that one week at the
grandparents Lake every year saying
listen with the money you're making cuz
you've got the successful thing once a
year you need to try a concept that is
yours because what will happen is either
it's just a good ontore
execution and this is a muscle you don't
have I always say to franchisees you
know I I speak at a lot of franchisee
conferences through the years and I'll
get off stage and I'll Crush because I'm
good like that like Gary like I love you
you and me are you know we're the same
we're entrepreneurs and I always say
this and this is not disrespectful I
need you to hear this because this is
the most fun way to answer your question
I go we're not the same my friend I'm an
entrepreneur you're you're
entrepreneurial you got when you're a
franchisee you are an entrepreneurial
person with training wheels
on
because when you're an entrepreneur you
do everything when you're a franchise e
yeah you do most things but not
everything I think the next step for you
versus using your infrastructure which
is smart I see the the energy drink I
see the slippers my gut is you've built
in a ridiculous core competency over the
last
decades you're educated the way I'm
educated from the streets from the
stores in the
trenches I find it inconceivable that
the two of you the three of you whoever
else is in the Inner Circle don't have
some idea of a taco a pizza a hot dog a
Philly cheese I don't know what you
think but there's always new Concepts
it's [__]
hard but I think it would be wildly
fruitful and enjoyable for you to try
because I believe you have too much
operational knowledge that even if it's
not a great concept you'll have a
one-store unit that does well and you
can just sell it off or you might just
want to have it for yourselves and if
you really made the qsr that you really
wish existed it will also be
enjoyable yeah true that's true thank
you um because that that is something is
you know I've always told people that
I'm not an entrepreneur I'm mean I'm a
franchisee I'm just following the
blueprint but we've always had that
Vision to do our own thing and and we
would love to do that and it is at this
point in life it's I want to do
something enjoyable really it's just
like you know take one like that like
and invent something like maybe you love
watermelon juice like you can go for it
you know this because you've been in the
game how long have you been in the game
now uh now I'm 50 we've been doing a
since I was 26 yeah so 24 years you've
seen some Concepts that people did not
think were gonna work right you you've
seen some stuff that is now H scale
right that you know when you read it in
the magazines or you heard about it or
I'm sure both of you look at each other
and be like [__] we shouldn't have we
shouldn't have passed on that one that
one did
well yes a ton of
times yes sir game I would say
that before you go into the ground and
You're Dead
Forever try one store your dream your
Aesthetics your menu your formula your
product just go for it once
yeah thank you my friend you just
watered the seed brother thank you you
know why brother here's why God forbid
you hit
it God forbid it's gamechanging that is
right the energy drink or this that's
solid but like you could CH and and you
know what as a franchisee at this level
of success with this many units it's
inconceivable to me that it hasn't
crossed your mind so [__] it and use the
amount of money that you can go to zero
on when you do it a million bucks five
million bucks two million bucks three
million I don't know you but do it at a
level where it can go to zero because it
is very hard but remember that the three
of you have and two of you for sure and
I don't know have all the relations but
you have the operational
capability
yeah I'm done Yes W I gotta get started
Gary finish this up here I got to get to
work on my dream so uh go ahead Justin
let Justin get his question in let let
me end here with you know Hospitality
franchising uh we we have a niche
audience and uh I do LinkedIn I've got
10,000 followers and we go to
conferences and people just kind of they
rant and Rave about what we're doing but
it's not necessarily resonating into
like call it our subscribers or
viewership or impression so like as
someone who's got an inner circle of
some you know what we say best-in-class
restaurant folks and Hospitality you've
got any ideas on the of short form
content that as an operator I can excel
in I'm I'm super connected into VRI I've
read the books could doing that's that's
kickass I think you should do Ask Gary
ve tea with Gary
ve I think you should do your version of
a Q&A show because then it it will go
deeper and then that concept will
resonate with who you're talking about
because it's hard to self-start on
details that we're talking about but if
you answer questions from this universe
you will get to the nerdy content which
will then make you go
further yeah the nerdy content that's
what we were talking about yeah very
cool we just started that it's hard for
me I'm great at this to just come up
with the nerdy content which is why I've
always done Q&A there's a reason I did
ask Gary ve there's a reason t with Gary
ve worked got
it yeah yeah I have I have two let's
wrap it up with this I like your like
the vibe I'd like to get to know y'all
better and get closer oh% yeah thank you
heck
yeah